i think most people when they make
content say what's in it for me i'm
gonna get likes i'm gonna get a customer
i'm gonna get that blue check mark i
think the reason i have the career i
have is from the first video i made
about wine on youtube in february 2006
to the stuff i put out today
my brain has always thought why would
anybody watch this
i think something i've been spending a
lot of time on recently is
the first five six years of someone's
life is so
and
formative
have this hypothesis lately that if you
are lucky enough
to be born into a family that doesn't
have a lot financially
but is incredibly happy and loving
you've started
life in a foundation that gives you a
massive advantage
because you realize that money is not
the answer to happiness
and i am that person i was born in the
soviet union
i got very fortunate to come to this
great country when i was three years old
and
life was super hard i lived with
nine family members in the studio
apartment the size of this stage in
queens
we grew up lower middle class the
majority of my early childhood but it
was a happy household my mom as you
mentioned quickly
is the hero of my life
and she uh instilled incredibly
massive
foundations for me around kindness and
empathy and compassion and all the
things i mean literally be friends the
ip that i'm building right now on the
back of nfts
which will have the biggest booth at
this convention in 10 years
is
really
is really really really
the seed of how my mother saw the world
my mom lost her mom at five grew up in
the soviet union
like real tough life and really showed
me
all the true answers to the world and so
i grew up
very very much not entitled my mom was
the sweetest as pie
but my mom is super cheap and we were
poor
so everything i ever wanted she looked
me in the face and said go get it so
lemonade stands washing cars shoveling
snow
you know i'm
built on hard work
uh i think entitlement is a disease i
think a lot of people have it today
and i'm very grateful i don't and um
i think we're all byproducts of our
childhood i think there's things that
i've had to work on just like anybody
else i think as grown-ups we can do that
you can't just say oh my parents [ __ ]
me up you know you've got to work at it
but
i am as grateful as one can be on earth
i've been writing a book in my head i've
written a lot of books but the one that
i've been holding nearest and dearest is
a book that i'm going to call perfectly
parented
i'm going to talk about how they did it
what they did and i hope it uh
creates different conversations because
i think parenting is one of the most
important conversations in the world
yeah no i love that
[Applause]
so
i had also incredible parents growing up
i my mom same thing gary was really
focused on inclusivity she whenever we
had people over whenever we did anything
whenever i was invited anywhere she
would say did you invite so-and-so did
you talk to someone so um we meet
and um you know i'll just be honest with
you when you're a little kid and you're
always having to include people in
conversations and invite people places
and make sure people are taken care of
is slightly annoying
and then as an adult you become this
person like you know what let's bring
this person
let's bring this person into the
conversation
and makes you a great leader it makes it
makes you a great person yeah right you
don't take advantage you don't look at
me we're going to get into leadership
but you know when you grow up with that
bedrock and people who actually care
about people care about other people's
feelings um i mean again i you know
again we share a lot in common but
having great parents
um is something that
you know i don't take for granted for a
second
on the flip side there's a lot of people
sitting here
my father's one of them i love my
grandma may she rest in peace but boy oh
boy she saw it different the thing that
inspires me daily and why i put myself
so out there and built the following
that i built and definitely why i'm
building v friends is
we have the capacity to change
humans inspire me so much
you know we're sitting here as the
byproduct of some good situations but
listen you and i had a bunch of stuff i
didn't know my dad at all he worked
every day of his life until i was 14.
like you know like everyone's got stuff
but
taking on the challenge of leaning into
optimism and figuring out whether it's
meditation exercise counseling uh
education the consumption of positive
content versus negative content or
whatever your path is i think it's
really inspiring that we have the
capacity to evolve as well and i and
that's what i spend my life on which is
i have a level of guilt and gratitude of
thinking i had a great situation and i
want to and continue to push the
conversation that if one doesn't
you have so much capacity to change your
outcome and i'm inspired by that
[Music]
i love that
all right so let's so so great
foundation yes i mean how do you not
applaud that great foundation
uh
and you always i mean listen we're at
the licensing shop we have to talk about
licensing and branding and laughing and
you have always been a collector
um big business collectibles um you've
always been very focused on branding i
want to ask you about your personal
brand versus your professional brand uh
and then also
the fact that you are um you're you've
been obsessed with intellectual property
in fact
uh many years ago gary and i were uh
talking and
we might even talk about spongebob i
don't know what he literally
i love intellectual properties one day
i'm either gonna buy one or i'm gonna
make one i mean that was a long time ago
and here we are
at the licensing show it's kind of weird
um and you have really thought a lot
about this space for a long time so talk
a little bit about
branding
um and talk a little bit about how you
got into then the licensing space
i'm 46 years old um
and that means i'm of the age where
1980s after school television of the 80s
cartoons were driving
well nickelodeon a little late you know
i loved pin well yes pinwheel i remember
early nickelodeon but but nickelodeon
really hit its scaled way that we know
it today that's right that's more aj
yeah i was more after school
he-man
thundercats transformers my little pony
strawberry shortcake the rebirth of g.i
talked a lot about strawberries
i love strawberry shortcake
and so these were brands that were being
built on the distribution of
after-school television there was a lot
that happened in the 70s and early 80s
on saturday morning but if you really
look at the moat of mid 80s early 80s
after school that was a monster of ip
building i was very affected by that
toys r us was like the holy grail i was
we were you know again we didn't have a
lot of money so on my birthday i got to
go there at you know wrestling wwf vince
mcmahon built ip through humans
there was just a lot going on during
that era as a lot of us know so i'm
affected by that baseball cards i like
selling things there's a lot of that
going on and so
i was really affected by that era and
then very honestly
communication has always come natural to
me so not only was i fascinated by
he-man but i was getting d's and f's in
school but getting a's and b's in
history because i thought coup d'etats
were fascinating like why would they
take the newspaper and the radio station
at the same time as the palace like why
does the radio and television and the
newspaper matter so much so for me to be
where i'm at at 46 years old somebody
could have easily figured that out at 12
based on what i was paying attention to
social media became very natural to me
because i knew that that was going to be
the new moat of brand building and
storytelling i mean
why brand why intellectual property
because religion is that
the world is only based on stories
stories that people have decided to
believe in
there's not a very big you know this may
be emotional for some people and i'm
saying this respectfully but the delta
between
religion and the marvel universe is much
smaller than people realize especially
when you start looking at some of the
most successful ips of all time you
break down star wars it gets real
religious real fast right and so
i think that people are
are
really in a place where they need to
attach to the emotions of stories we've
done around campfires we do it today on
roblox and minecraft and everything in
between and so i've always been
fascinated by it i've always been a
collector i was a very heavy toy
collector in the mid 90s i properly felt
that sports cards were about to collapse
i sold my entire collection and went
heavy into toy collecting uh i was in
the right age when ebay came out i'd
been garage saleing and buying ip stuff
for years
it's just always come very natural to me
to the point where i
the level of happiness i have in
developing the friends for the rest of
my life is profound i've never seen it
it's it's
when i and i'll tell you why because the
garyvee thing
kind of sucks having a personal brand's
amazing but it comes with enormous
baggage
you know you get hate thrown at you you
get assumptions about you
uh and you know you're a human being
you're just taking on for me
i've been willing to do that because i
believe in kindness and gratitude and i
know that i'm a unique communicator and
that i can get things into the world and
i want to leave it better than i came
into it if i can
but a countable aunt my character
accountable aunt like for me right now
the lack of accountability is why so
many people are anxious accountability
is an incredible human trait that leads
to happiness
yet we've demonized accountability
we've demonized merit
we
created entitlement because we decided
to have an era of ninth place trophies
and we've created a lot of structures
that have demonized losing when actually
losing is foundationally phenomenal
and so for me knowing how i'm gonna make
an iphone game
or build in the metaverse or do
children's books or do an animation show
on a streaming service around the trials
and tribulations of a countable ant
if i can affect a generation to think
accountability is cool versus the
current generation that wants to point
fingers at everything and never point
the thumb at themselves i can make the
world a better place
[Music]
so so what i know is i've built one of
the largest social media platforms in
the world off of no distribution in real
world all social that's been fun i like
it but i don't need you know me i don't
need it it's not what i want it's the
message that i want and i've used myself
as a vehicle the ip allows me to make
that 500x and what i saw faces i saw
people understand like i've got six or
seven things i want to put into the
earth in a different way i want to show
young men
that you can build an empire
and be kind not a dick
so
so um
before we get there i want to i want to
go back a little bit just a little bit
uh yeah
because one of the things what i think
is so amazing about what you're doing is
you you hit the nail on that and that is
i think one of the things we all love
about the business of brand is emotional
connection and for a lot of years this
business was very transactional yeah it
was listed in vip and put it on product
and um
it is really about building grounds and
uh you know i didn't grow up with the
licensing industry i came to it uh at
the company i was working in marketing
marketing is about creating consumer
connections and the privilege of working
across some of the most iconic brands in
the world like spongebob turtles etc is
that this means a lot to people
a lot and and to your point some of
these
shows and characters and brands have
been with us in times that are really
really challenging and i think that
that's what this business is that's why
this business is so exciting and that's
where you're seeing so much growth and
so you know you are literally the
perfect person to step into this space
because of your foundation about
understanding the importance of the
brain the importance of brand
before we go to be friends um
you are a brit gary let's just say in a
minute and talk about gary b
gary vaynerchuk and gary vee and
you know this is a personal question how
do you unpack it i mean you are how do
you separate that you are a very private
person
living a very public life
and now you're going to be more public
because of what you created and
obviously then how do you distinguish
between the two i tell people all the
time you're in control
like you're in control of what you put
out into the world i i deal with it and
unpack it very easily
i put into the world what i'm willing to
share
and i don't what i'm not willing to
share and too many people get caught up
in the game
they want likes they want followers they
want the blue check mark and what what
usually does well kids
family stuff but as a private person
that's not something i'm willing to
share on the flip side i'm willing to be
the most
intellectually generous around
everything that's ever worked for me i
think the thing that works for me is
when i make a piece of content
i think most people when they make
content say what's in it for me i'm
going to get likes i'm going to get a
customer i'm going to get that blue
check mark i think the reason i have the
career i have is from the first video i
made about wine on youtube in february
2006 to the stuff i put out today
my brain has always thought why would
anybody watch this
like like why are you watching this like
why is this good for you and for me
i have always lived
abundance company
going to talk about under
[Music]
that's so fantastic thank you anyway
you know i
i respect people's time i
don't have entitlement i think i have to
fight for it and so i
spent a lot of time reading my direct
messages and my emails
to try to figure out where the
temperature is in the world and what are
the issues and what are the
opportunities what do people struggle
with what have i i never talk about
anything i've never done
so i think one thing that's really
worked for me is i don't talk about
stuff i don't know
i never tell people to do something i
haven't
because done really really unusual you
will not
endorse or talk about anything i'm very
narrow i love your recent article i
think i just read where you talked about
how people were endorsing entities that
they didn't even experience crazy what
is that
so people talk a little bit about that
it's this it's this it's this industry
i'll make a really interesting copy you
brought it up and i've watched this
industry from afar for a long time i
think the reason the industry is doing
better
macro is we become less transactional
people are protecting their brand they
don't need the brand in every category
to maximize the p l they realize if they
make some sort of silly thing for
short-term money it might hurt their
overall thing that's how i've always
thought i've been very patient i never
do anything that can tarnish me i really
work on that i i think it's important i
don't i just don't know how any level of
money is worth you not putting your head
on a pillow at night it doesn't make
sense to me it's not how i see the world
um and so i focus on that i also think
the world is abundant i also am
incredibly patient
you know i spent the first 12 years of
my career building my dad's business for
him i started my company at 34 years old
in another company's
conference room because we had no money
i was 34 before i ever made 100 000 a
year like
you can accomplish a lot everyone's so
anxious everyone wants it so fast
everybody wants to keep up with the
joneses they want to make it now so they
can show or enjoy like to me enjoy the
process of your career not the money you
make from your career so you can then
enjoy it
and that's the game i play so a lot of
us here
the book he recently written
which i will talk about because he will
um
emotional ingredients
i cut it i got
leveraging it emotional ingredients
necessary for business success and
this book the minute i got it i sent him
a note that this resonates because it's
what he's one of the few people in the
industry
and
most importantly the soft skills which i
completely agree with you are so
undervalued and so i just want you to
talk to this room before we get into uh
obviously
i wanted to talk about your perspective
on that so important i think business
has a bad name i think we've misbranded
business
the brand of business is broken i think
a lot of people have very honorable very
kind business skills and the world
thinks businesses rough and sharp elbows
and
nice
like
even like it just made me like jump up a
little bit this concept that the world
has been pushing on us that nice guys
finish last is a travesty no it's a
travesty that people believe that
it makes people behave in ways that they
don't have in their soul
and it's broken and i think we have to
have a new conversation i think hard
skills are commoditized machine learning
ai many other things that's where the
commodity is it's the people that know
how to lead too many people lead out of
fear
it's not healthy it doesn't work in the
end and i just think we need to have a
more thoughtful conversation i think if
you look under the hood and pay
attention the most meaningful long-term
things have been built far more on good
behavior than bad behavior you can get
short-term results through fear and
negativity but it is not a sustainable
action and
i think it's time we talk about it and
how many times have you shut down a
conversation
when you walk past someone's office cube
conference wherever you are and
someone's being yelled at but
i i just wrote that down
pam i just need to understand
how anybody believes that verbally
undressing another human being in a
business meeting ever has any reasoning
and i just want everybody to hear this
i'm not talking about let's do foofy
foofy entitlement everyone's now
thinking about like what about these
[ __ ] gen zeros they don't want to do
[ __ ] i'm not talking about that
i'm not talking about like we have to do
stuff of course i'm talking about
people using negativity and and fear as
drivers yeah
nobody wants to be scared of their boss
so many people so many people are
struggling when i'm pushing this out
because they're worried about
entitlement and i understand that
it is a fine balance
but
we just need to have a different combo
because you get way more out of honey
than vinegar it is documented proof but
most of all the thing that bothers me
the most is i watch nice people
navigate their careers and try to
develop less nice skills because they
believe subconsciously and consciously
that it gets them further and that has
to be eradicated
i totally agree let's give a [ __ ] to
that
and i i again i i love the way you're
weaving that message in back and forth
it's so important okay more i got the i
got the time frame so i'm going to move
to v con so um
you just made your dream come true for
uh for a long time you dreamt about what
vcon could be
you've talked um about what three you've
talked about
nmt's you talked about uh obviously you
have been a leading voice in this space
uh and i want to talk a little bit about
how was the weekend
how'd it go for the majority of you that
don't know the context this weekend in
minnesota at u.s bank stadium where the
vikings play
we had something called v-con
it's a really interesting convoluted
mixed answer several things one i'm very
close to the will family that owns the
stadium or or has the bike owns the
vikings they grew up in springfield new
jersey where my dad's wine store is so
there's good relationship feels family i
like doing business with people
this one's going to be a loop but it's
tying in nicely to what i've said i
think america has gotten very red and
very blue like very red and very blue i
think a lot of people now feel they have
to be 100 red and 100
blue in a world where every person
sitting here has some level of purple
so i'm falling in love with this concept
of purple it's where i want to go with
my content it's where i want to go with
the friends as much as i'm excited about
kind could do and empathy elephant and
patient panda i'm equally as excited
about developing ambitious angel and
tenacity you know termite and you know
competitive clown that like makes kids
cry when they lose like you know so it's
a i would call and so because i want to
make it purple
competitive clown is a character and be
friends and the main story arc is i
think it's good when kids cry when they
lose
[Applause]
and i think we spent the last 25 years
trying to not make them cry stop them
from crying not let crying happen it
means they care
i think being competitive is a
massively attractive skill like anything
in life anything out of balance is bad
but we tried to wipe it out
and and so i have a very purple view on
the world i think the deep red deep blue
reality of what we're sitting in right
now has created incredible levels of
non-civility lots of angst tons of
anxiety
and i want to march to purple and that
stadium is purple
so it was a very secret little thing for
me
[Applause]
[Music]
i love prince
little red corvette is still top 10
songs of all time
i need to work on the jet super bowl
[ __ ] the vikings
so you're excited with the outfit yeah i
mean i think listen let's let's make it
valuable for this crowd
everybody in here is going to figure out
how significant the consumer blockchain
is over the next 15 years
this
audience here is probably nft curious
because there's economics that there's
money it's definitely in the air right
now we're in a gold rush phase where
everything's about the economics the
numbers are crazy it's internet 97. just
like in 97 and 98 and 99 the stocks were
too valued they crashed but the internet
and the macro was going to change the
world
98 of the nft projects in the space
right now are going to zero they're
going to be misoperated people don't
know what to do with the ip it's using
the short greed economics but they're
not going to navigate i.p development
and value and they'll go to zero but
nfts consumer nfts will impact every
single person in this room for the rest
of your lives
wow
because the technology's too big every
ticket to every sporting event and
concert in seven years is going to be an
nft people are going to buy homes in the
form of the night of tv
talk about real estate well when you do
real estate you're buying a home that
sits on a ledger at the county level or
at the state level like people don't
understand that the consumer blockchain
is a ledger that proves
ownership
and has smart contract capability this
is very very significant we spend lots
of money
on companies in the middle that provide
no value that are just toll booths that
we're not going to do that with because
there's now technology no different than
people now buy things on it and have it
delivered to them even though in 1997
when everybody asked me gary who's going
to buy wine on the internet my answer
every time was everybody
and every and you know there's some ogs
in here in 1997 that didn't click in
2006 when i told everybody that
everybody was going to have a social
media account a twitter they're like
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
heard of who cares if you're walking the
dog or having a pizza and my answer was
everybody
and it didn't register to people but
that's what humans are we're a bunch of
yentas we want to know people's business
you know and so
so
but more importantly it's the flip side
besides our curiosity and wanting to
know
people need to communicate
the reason social media worked is you
want to show everybody your new car you
want to show everybody your family is
having a great time at disney it's what
people do they used to do it by taking
100 photos coming back and having their
four friends come over and look at the
photos this just created technology
scale the reason people buy bmws the
reason people buy nikes rolex's louis
vuitton burka is the same reason
everyone's going to buy nfts to show and
communicate but
it's also going to have utilitarian
value the 8 000 people 7 000 people that
came to bcon this weekend in minnesota
were only able to come if they owned a v
friend
so this is going to change the world
it's going to eat up this conference in
10 years
the concept of nfts whether they're
called nfts or we came up with some new
world is going to be the dominant
infrastructure of this conference let me
make a more profound statement there's
actually no logical sense no logical
sense for anybody to establish a ip ever
again
in book form cartoon form toy form
youtube form all of it
well all of it makes more sense to start
as an nft to establish the ip rights on
the blockchain and then you can develop
it
there is no path to ip building that
doesn't start with step one minted on
the blockchain because you get a royalty
component for every transaction in
perpetuity
[Applause]
so brands will definitely matter going
forward brands matter forever
right like look do you know why the
world is a religious place because
churches and religious institutions were
the fastest mover on the printing press
and the printed press changed the world
like this has always been about
communication
this has always been about communication
everybody here over the age of 45
grossly underestimated the internet 25
years ago
every single person sitting here right
now is grossly under estimating nfts and
a lot of people here have opinions about
it because of one headline they saw on
twitter or their friends said something
the amount of people pam i apologize the
amount of people
who've spent 50 hours here actually
educating themselves on what the
blockchain is what entities are what
aetherium is is very far and few between
i've seen this rodeo three times in my
short career
this movie always plays out this
conference
is grossly
grossly underestimating what the [ __ ] is
happening yes i i love that
the early pioneers who are establishing
ip no different than the 1980s were
where the storytellers were like wait a
minute this cartoon mode is amazing i'm
going to do a cartoon to sell these toys
at toys r us this is a moat for ip
building so the same dna that made the
production companies and the ip builders
understand that this moat of 83 82 to 88
of ip building right on television when
you think about turtles comic book
but those cartoons took it to the
stratosphere yeah right and so the
people that are getting it right
are putting themselves in that position
me yam from world of women the board ape
crew we're all getting our bats we've
got a lot of work to do there's been a
hundred million dollars of v friends
sold in the first year on primary
there's been 250 million sold in
secondary that i make between 5.5 and 10
royalties on every transaction this has
happened one year v friends has bigger
and better p l economics than 98 of this
room
it didn't exist a year ago
amazing
it but it's not that amazing it's a
timing execution thing there's a but you
said yourself you didn't expect it i
didn't i'm just saying it's why i'm
saying not amazing because a lot of it's
coming from greed on the other side
people think it's how they're going to
become a millionaire and i'm like keep
saying like don't spend money you can't
afford to lose slow down like i love the
correction that's happened in pricing
the last three weeks because it gets
some of the riffraff out of the system
but you have to understand when you're
sitting with ip and you issue nfts but
then you can trigger experiences every
ip in here can do a pop-up museum in new
york city that only can get into if you
have the nft like there's so much more
you look at the music industry you think
about the wealth that prince or bruce
springsteen or michael jackson or the
beatles created people in music have
made so much money because they've had
royalties in perpetuity for the first
time ever at scale on the consumer end
we can do that with ip that's a big deal
[Music]